you want to know who's really ticked off
about that op-ed by an anonymous but
very important trump official this guy I
wouldn't have used it to very well too
vague and not does not meet the
standards of trying to describe specific
incidents specific incidents are the
building blocks of journalism now why
would Bob say that that's an insider's
view he knows that the Times ran that
piece to trim the sales of his new book
and hurt the paper's chief rival The
Washington Post The Times was Tonya
Harding and Woodward was Nancy Kerrigan
taken out the legs of Bob's book at the
perfect time so who wrote the piece well
it didn't tell us anything so doesn't
really matter if the writers claiming to
secretly control Trump's harmful
impulses why write an op-ed piece for
The Times that seems like the worst
thing you do to control his impulses
it's like shooting yourself in the foot
halfway through a marathon so whoever
wrote this didn't think it through and
it could be absolutely anybody anybody
madis sure
Pompeyo okay Ivanka definitely probably
the assistant deputy secretary of
commerce why not Doris and shipping yeah
in fact if anything is possible why not
some guy at the Times the Jason Blair of
the moment somebody acting out of
concern to save America just like the
piece said crazier things have happened
the times once endorsed the Anthony
Weiner so if Trump wants to out the
op-ed operative all he's got to say is
hey we looked into everyone here so it
must be somebody at the x must be could
be what's the difference so yeah it
could be the undersecretary for ditches
and pipes or it could be Paul Krugman
except even The Times knows if they put
Krugman's name on it nobody read it
never miss a chance wad to hit Krugman
shouldn't it without further notice Juan
I'm going to assume that the Times wrote
it until they prove otherwise
because the thing is they should want to
clear their name by proving to me that
that somebody else wrote it really yes
you to think you have that much
authority they're really they're hungry
you're worried about me why because I
worry that you're going a little far
into the Trump camp here yes I'm trying
to do but you know what I mean your
point I think you made this point a lot
of people have been critical to this
anonymous writer
yeah like yesterday on Fox News Sunday
the the senator from Delaware [ __ ] said
you know I thinks people shouldn't have
done it if you think you're have some
responsible if you really want to make a
statement like that stand up yeah say it
with your name attached to it but I will
say I don't get your point about
Woodward's book it seems to me that he
is highly credible so whereas in the
Amoroso case you could say or even in
the Michael Wolf case you could say I
don't know but in this case you'd say
this guy is a veteran journalist with
one unbelievable track record and what
he says is this president is detached
from reality yeah but I guess my point
is is that he realized the New York
Times did drop it I think that it
actually helps him does it yes because
controversy helps drives books so he's
gonna be doing a ton of interviews I'm
gonna have with him on Wednesday on the
daily briefing show plug one of the
things that helps people if they have a
book out because there's so many books
happening is if there's a controversy
that you are somewhat related to you'll
always be asked about it and it keeps
you in the top of the headlines ah judge
what do you think who do you think wrote
this of the op-ed piece I think the New
York Times wrote it but what do I know
no one knows here's here's the problem
the problem with this thing is if if
there's a two-track system according to
the letter in the White House where
we're keeping everybody on track
otherwise it'd be crazy town which is
the word that Woodward uses I think or
one of them uses and they attributed to
Kelly then if it's so crazy in the White
House why aren't people like hanging
themselves from the chandeliers I mean
why is everything happening that the
president said was going to happen
I'm gonna take care of the economy gonna
take care of unemployment I'm gonna get
rid of Isis I'm gonna do what's so crazy
about that the guy who did everything he
said he was going to do and I
should be worried the country's in bad
hands these people are crazy
have you noticed the high rate of people
fleeing this White House oh come on they
did the same thing with Clinton in the
beginning it was chaos this is illegal
but you know what here's the thing
you've got a guy who was never in
government he was in business he didn't
even have a group that he could rely on
that he had worked with for twenty years
preparing for this job so of course
they're gonna be a lot more people going
to know you should talk to Jesse about
what Jesse Tommy Trump is only hiring
the best because this explains a lot of
the liars and the leakers and the
liberal doesn't like their business
being questioned especially by a
businessman so he comes in because why
the hell are we still in Afghanistan
after all these years yeah we have all
these troops in South Korea and they're
ripping us off on trade you know why the
hell is our immigration system rigged
against us and you have all these people
around the swamp that have been in there
for years have set up all these
institutions and the international order
and they take offense to that they say
hey we yeah we set this whole thing up
and Trump's all he's saying is why we
didn't really engineered the system
which is I make a better sizing is the
fact that Trump says why are we giving
all these other countries money and
somebody had to come in and say if we
don't give money we'll have World War
three he says he asked these questions
he uses very blunt colorful and
entertaining language yeah all these
insiders and a lot of guys oh hired they
go oh my god did you hear what he said
and it's so fresh you got a leak it you
got a spill it and then that gets out
there and it gets spun here's the bottom
line if you don't like it in there
then get out all right what's with just
what's happening and that's good maybe
that's what you're talking and again I
did about Woodward
if Woodward transcribed my behavior I
would be institutionalized what do you
what he does is he's a good stenographer
but he doesn't tell the whole story he
just has the stuff but he doesn't have
context or tone so 90% of my life off
camera is babbling nonsense
yes yes so I I'm glad he doesn't follow
me around well you know what strikes me
though is like in the Woodward case he
says well here's the document that was
taken off the President's desk and
people are saying oh not true no here's
the documents of fact okay so in other
words Gary Cohen
Rob port all these guys who left they're
all nuts but the president thought you
know what I ran an office somebody took
a piece of paper off of my desk I'd be
looking for you they'd be missing a hand